I will see the paycheck about you but
the sweet cash coming in because my kids
want things and food and shelter and
that kind of thing if you're a comedy
writer your hang out with funny people
every day and you go into work and
everyone's really funny and it's like
it's you know and then when I'm just
hanging out in the suburbs it's like
these guys aren't that funny my butcher
can be funny on occasion but it's not
consistent and there's the excitement of
putting the show on having a show every
day and all that kind of thing when you
work for the late night show you have
you know these celebrities that come in
every day and you see them and it's kind
of turn the corner and Slyke all these
Tom Hanks the crowd comes in they're
excited and that is sort of a feel I
think everyone sort of feels that
excitement of the show and it's kind of
a little adrenaline rush not having that
every day is it's strange i missed the
paycheck and i miss structure i miss
structured in my day you know someplace
to be it nine o'clock i missed due dates
you know like when you write a movie
right to be sure they tell you you have
to turn the movie in three months from
tomorrow now my entire life is
structured around that dude it so
everything I'm gonna take a vacation I
need to do it not the last month because
I know the last month are going to get
kind of hectic and um but without due
dates up my life has reformed
that's where they had we're weird George
Clooney and Fabio almost in a fight they
were seated at two different tables in
some la restaurant and then there's some
kind of problem with Lucy's crouppen
five yrs grouped and Colonia fat he
almost had a fight and there's like a
shoving match between the two of them
and then people get it's like oh come on
you can't take that away from us just
hearing that story on TV would have been
great you have the whole primaries now
and all that stuff and there's a lot of
candidates you have you know you have
Hillary Huckabee there's so many
personalities and me have Fred Thompson
is Fred Thompson's trying to be present
I mean he was even the star of law and
order so to become president like that's
a huge leap right i mean like he should
have at least been in the sam waterston
role we'll see if you can handle that
then we'll make the the big jump plus
you have Bill Clinton's out there
campaigning so there's a lot of stuff up
there that we we can't touch it we you
know can't get our hands on I think the
candidates are probably glad not to have
the ridicule what a relief to them I
think the general public has always had
a bitter understanding what writers do
them the actual studios and networks um
because the studios and networks always
treat us like we are the you know the
low man the totem pole but people have a
pretty good understanding of what
writers do in her appreciative of it and
I feel like you know I've heard nothing
but support from people I there's not a
single presidents walked up to me and
said like right what are you doing
there's plenty of times when you see a
movie where the actors are good and the
special effects are good so it's a bad
movie because it wasn't well written I
do think you're right i think the studio
has no concept that we have any value
but i think the public feels different
I feel like it says all the time I have
a wife that works and they don't have a
whole family I you know kids are big
mortgage or I mean I'm lucky that I can
get through this time and and you don't
want to look at it or think about it in
terms of if it goes so long that well
how I start to feel against the Union
anyway because we support the Union and
we support what we're doing and my kids
teeth it's doesn't look pretty straight
to me a few months ago 0 he's there now
so it actually not bad races our expense
yeah I have some friends in la who are
real doomsdayers you know they're really
really worried about that's going and
they're like I'm gonna go meet with a
headhunter like what are you gonna do
right yeah I am I can't do anything yeah
I can't fix anything I can't you're just
funny so that's not marketable I kind of
blew it yeah I do stand up so I can at
least make thirty or forty dollars a
week I don't know if it's happened a
long term what if i can get my wife to
go to walmart yeah apply there
you